Here are the correct expressions. If you got these, excellent work. I know these
last two were pretty tricky. So, it's okay if you didn't get them right on your
first try. First, we can distribute the 5th power to the 7 squared and the x
squared. Now, we apply our power to our power rule. We multiply 2 times 5 to get
7 to the 10th. And 2 times 5 to get x to the 10th. We could only distribute this
power of 5, because they had factors here. Numbers and variables multiplied
together. Then next one, we distribute the square to 3 to the 1, n cubed and n
squared. And we get this. We multiply the exponents together to get 3 squared. N
to the 6th, and n to the 4th. Finally, for the last one, we carry out the same
steps. We have a cubed, cubed. B squared cubed and c to the 1 cubed. Raising a
power to a power. We get a to the 9th, b to the 6th and c cubed. There's our
final answer.